zusammen herzlich willkommen bei zdf
heute live an euren empfangsgeräten wir
haben eine pandemie wir haben ein
ziemlich großer streit zwischen der
bundesregierung und den bundesländern
die diese pandemie jetzt endlich mal
schlussendlich zu bekämpfen ist denn wir
haben ja noch eine bundestagswahl in
diesem jahr aber was die union dann noch
nicht hat ist einen passenden
kanzlerkandidaten klar ist nur es wird
diesmal wohl ein mann werben den
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel tritt er
nicht wieder an das war es aber schon
mit der einigkeit zwischen cdu und csu
denn die sind gerade sehr
unterschiedlicher meinung darüber wer
von diesen beiden herren für sie ins
rennen ziehen soll das cdu präsidium hat
sich heute morgen hinter nrw
ministerpräsident und cdu chef armin
laschet gestellt die csu dass cds csu
präsidium hat das heute nachmittag auch
getan allerdings für markus söder csu
chef und bayerischer ministerpräsident
mitten in der pandemie haben wir also
einen schönen schwestern streit in der
union ordentlich tief in der derzeit
noch größten bundestagsfraktion und die
große frage was ist da los
und was machen wir jetzt damit darüber
reden wir heute unter anderem mit dem
politikwissenschaftler karl rudolf korte
und mit unserem münchner korrespondenten
alexander pohl den ich jetzt auch gleich
mal begrüßen möchte und meine erste
frage an dich lieber alexander ist
markus söder hat auch immer gesagt mein
platz ist in bayern was man bei dir
hinten schön sieht im bild da in münchen
warum denn jetzt auf einmal doch der zug
nach berlin
also ich glaube markus söder hat sich
die ganze zeit über eigentlich für den
besseren kanzlerkandidaten gehandelt
gehalten
das war auch schon so als die cdu
nachfolgefrage noch gar nicht
entschieden war also noch armin laschet
norbert röttgen und friedrich merz waren
die sich um den cdu vorsitz beworben
haben schon zu dieser zeit hat markus
söder im grunde genommen sich selbst für
den besten kanzlerkandidaten gehalten
den die union stellen könnte
und das hat sich auch nicht geändert
erstaunlich fand ich heute eigentlich
bei der pressekonferenz der csu wie
nervös die csu dann doch reagiert hat
also man muss sich vorstellen wir sitzen
alle in diesem raum zusammen und bis
kurz vor der pressekonferenz wurde uns
gesagt markus blume also der
generalsekretär würde
die pressekonferenz sozusagen alleine
abhalten da haben wir uns ziemlich
gewundert sind sämtliche journalisten
kollegen eigentlich gefragt warum markus
söder nicht selber kommt warum er nicht
wie armin laschet ja auch nach der
präsidiumswahl der vorstandsitzung hier
rede und antwort gestanden hat warum
würde dass markus söder nicht machen das
ging ging ein großes spekulieren hin und
her und erst kurz vor der
pressekonferenz dann hat man uns
eigentlich gesagt okay jetzt kommt
markus söder dann doch das war aus
unserer sicht ein zeichen dafür wie
nervös man in der csu ist und wie
vielleicht auch gar nicht wirklich so
einig darüber welchen kurs man jetzt
erfahren soll ob diese entscheidung
jetzt bei der cdu in berlin
wir haben auch einen kleinen ausschnitt
aus dieser pressekonferenz aus dem
statement von markus söder das hören wir
uns jetzt mal zusammen an
normalerweise ist ja so eine partei
vorstand entscheidet dann gibt es eine
euphorische stimmung an der basis die
freuen sich alle dass die entscheidung
gefällt wird zumindest glaube ich gibt
es da noch diskussionsbedarf und jetzt
müssen wir die nächsten tage auch
synchronisieren wir müssen hineinhorchen
wir leben in einer modernen form der
demokratie nicht zehn zwanzig oder
dreißig leute entscheiden allein sondern
wahlen gewinnt man nur mit einer
richtigen ja breiten unterstützung und
aktiv mitgliederschaft die bereit ist zu
kämpfen
ja so weit also markus söder heute in
einem presse statement zu seiner
kanzlerkandidatur kann man ja sagen
zumindest hat er gesagt ich will es
machen alexander pohl unser
korrespondent in münchen das ist doch
eigentlich nach dem was er gerade gesagt
hat so ein klares sorry die leute haben
doch eigentlich überhaupt keine lust auf
armin laschet nimmt mich denn ich bin
beliebter oder genau also da verweist
hier auf die umfragewerte die
tatsächlich für ihn ja auch sehr hoch
sind also wenn man die unionsanhänger
fragt das gab es in den letzten wochen
ja häufiger da waren ja dann über 60
prozent haben sich für markus söder
ausgesprochen
dasselbe ja auch im zdf politbarometer
wenn es um die frage ging wer eignet
sich als besserer kanzlerkandidat auch
da liegt markus söder ja weit vor armin
laschet und was jetzt beginnt ist dass
markus söder in den tiefen der cdu ich
möchte jetzt mal so formulieren in der
breite der cdu nach diesen stimmen sucht
deswegen geht er morgen vor die fraktion
deswegen sagt er man muss auch die basis
mit einbeziehen
markus söder hofft
auf dass die leute die menschen die
politiker die sich in den umfragen für
ihn ausgesprochen haben
dass sie sich jetzt auch zb in der
fraktion melden dass die sich an der
basis melden und das am ende sozusagen
immer mehr stimmen dann kommen die sagen
naja markus söder ist vielleicht doch
der bessere dass das am ende passiert
halte ich für extrem unwahrscheinlich
also wenn sich der das der cdu-vorstand
und das cdu-präsidium eindeutig für
armin laschet ausgesprochen haben jetzt
sozusagen hintenrum von hinten durch die
brust ins auge dann doch noch eine
kanzlerkandidatur für sich anzustreben
das halte ich für relativ aussichtslos
es wirkt ein bisschen so als wolle da
jemand die spielregeln ändern nachdem er
gesehen hat also gut ist es für mich
vielleicht doch nicht gelaufen ich guck
mal in die kommentare
natürlich könnt ihr uns fragen stellen
zu diesem wert weiß merkwürdigen
vorgehen in der union da gerade wo es
natürlich viel klärungsbedarf gibt oder
auch gerne per mail übrigens an zdf
heute - live at zdf.de das kriege ich
auch hier weiter gereicht da unten
nochmal die e mail adresse es gibt hier
eine frage zum beispiel oder ein ja ich
würde mal ein statement sagen dass
alexander du vielleicht noch mal kurz
einordnen kann es von south stream ist
söder nicht nur wegen seiner corona
politik gefragt davor war er ja nicht
besonders beliebt was meinst du dazu
naja was er was man schon sagen muss ist
dass er einen gehörigen anteil daran hat
dass die beiden schwesterparteien sich
wieder gut verstehen
das ist glaube ich etwas was ihm hoch
angerechnet wird da das damals auch
schon als annegret kramp karrenbauer
noch cdu-chefin war er hat sozusagen die
grimm wieder zugeschüttet die durch den
streit zwischen horst seehofer und
angela merkel in der flüchtlingspolitik
aufgekommen sind
dass er natürlich in der krise so ein
bisschen seine politische heimat hat das
sagen viele
markus söder ist ein typ politiker der
in der krise so zu sagen über sich
hinaus wächst weil er so rüberkommt als
könne er das alles managen als habe er
alles im blick das ist schon etwas was
ihm sehr zu gute kommt die frage ist und
das ist ja im grunde auch dass das
andere thema das einen darauf spielt der
armin laschet immer sehr stark ab dass
es eben nicht nur darum
geht jetzt stärke zu zeigen von vorne zu
führen sondern eben auch das land zu
einen und das ist etwas was armin
laschet vielleicht eher zugesprochen
wird als markus söder
wer jetzt vielleicht noch nicht so
richtig im blick hat der markus söder
eigentlich ist wo der herkommt da haben
wir jetzt noch mal ein kleinen
einspieler in einer kurze ein kurzes
porträt von jan friedrich fischer damit
wir alle auf dem gleichen stand sind
lange wurde spekuliert ob er es macht
lange ließ er offen
gemeint ist markus söder der csu
politiker ist 54 jahre alt und gibt seit
2008 zehn als ministerpräsident den takt
in bayern an
ein jahr später übernimmt er zusätzlich
den parteivorsitz söder gilt als
zielstrebig steigt in der partei früher
auf als andere und sorgt immer wieder
für diskussionen etwa mit dem kreuz
ahlers in bayern oder seiner wortwahl in
der asyldebatte
asül tourismus asyl tourismus auf sylt
tourismus der protest an zwar hat die
csu als minister immer weiter auf sich
ausgerichtet und versucht der partei
einen frischen anstrich zu geben
in der pandemie inszeniert er sich dann
als kümmerer als staatsmann er setzt auf
klare worte und auf ein vermeintlich
schnelles und hartes durchgreifen
das kommt an 56 prozent sagten ende märz
um zdf-politbarometer markus söder würde
sich als bundeskanzler eignen nur 36
prozent sehen das nicht so
ein vorteil für söder der den zwist
gestern aber noch vermeintlich ausweicht
mein angebot
ich will nichts erzwingen im so wie es
vielleicht die csu früher gern gemacht
hat sehr lautstark auftretend erzwingen
sondern ein angebot für eine gemeinsame
basis
die cdu spitze das scheint festzustehen
scheint nicht begeistert von diesem
angebot
da ist man hier die kommentare sie hier
gleich als erstes auf facebook von
helmut gassen den kommentar silber ist
ein selbstverliebter egomane und ein
fähnchen im wind das ist ein ziemlich
hartes urteil aber trotzdem ist ein
bisschen die frage er ist ein mensch mit
zug zur macht das haben wir glaube ich
jetzt auch in diesem kurzen beitrag von
jan frederik gesehen der schon sehr früh
wusste was er wollte was meinst du wie
verhält er sich jetzt weiter erster 54
hat auch ein bisschen zeit eigentlich
auch ne ja gut das könnte natürlich eine
rechnung sein dass er sagt genau also
dass ich so je stärker ich jetzt
auftritte desto mehr hatten nämlich auch
in erinnerung wenn es dann zur nächsten
bundestagswahl geht er zunächst einmal
ist es glaube ich so diese zeit hat er
ja wie geht es jetzt weiter
es wird jetzt gespräche geben eben in
der fraktion da wird er morgen sprechen
zusammen mit armin laschet und dann
passiert eben genau dieser prozess ich
glaube dass er dann noch mal versucht
auch zu zeigen wie viel rückhalt er dann
tatsächlich in der partei an der basis
an der parteibasis vielleicht auch in
der fraktion da haben sich ja auch in
der tat einige für markus söder
ausgesprochen also das wird jetzt
sozusagen seine strategie sein die
strategie die er eigentlich in den
letzten wochen immer schon gefahren hat
die wird er fortsetzen das ein bisschen
auf zermürbung setzen also dass er nicht
locker lässt das ist ja auch etwas was
er sehr gut kann und das ist etwas so
kämpft markus so oder so
wenn ich das sagen am ende wie gesagt
glaube ich würde er sich die realität
stellen müssen dass wenn die gremien der
cdu sich ganz klar für ihren parteichef
armin laschet ausgesprochen haben dass
er sich dem dann auch wird fügen müssen
dann sind gespannt wie es weitergeht du
wirst das ganze weiter für uns
beobachten in bayern aus münchen heraus
alexander für heute einen laster vielen
dank dafür
und auf der anderen seite also quasi auf
der cdu seite steht eben armin laschet
ministerpräsident von nrw cdu chef und
die an frederick fisher hat ihn auch für
uns kurz porträtiert
im internen unions kanzlerduell gibt er
sich siegesgewiss
armin laschet der 60 jährige steht seit
2017 als ministerpräsident an der spitze
der schwarz gelben regierung in nrw seit
januar ist der cdu bundesvorsitzender
nach einem erbitterten internen
machtkampf laschet geht in der partei
als liberal und steht er für ein weiter
so nach der ära merkel während der
korona krise gerät der cdu-chef in die
bredouille
da sind diskussionen über öffnungs
schritte incidents werte oder masten
bestellungen und nicht zuletzt der
brücken lockdown dabei hagelt es nicht
nur unverständnis von der opposition
sondern auch vom koalitionspartner und
aus den eigenen reihen
das alles drückt einer der wichtigsten
politischen währungen die umfragewerte
lediglich 23 prozent sagten ende märz im
zdf-politbarometer armin laschet würde
sich als bundeskanzler eigenen 65
prozent sehen das nicht so
doch laschet und das cdu präsidium geben
sich selbstbewusst also natürlich sind
die umfrageergebnisse auch erörtert
worden
aber alle haben deutlich gemacht und
jeder hatte unzählige beispiele bei der
hand die umfragen sich innerhalb
kürzester zeit auch verändern können
daran muss er jetzt arbeiten fünf monate
zeit bleiben ihm fünf monate zeit sind
nicht so viel und darüber spreche ich
jetzt mit dem politikwissenschaftler
karl rudolf korte wir haben also einen
ausgewachsenen schwestern streit
zwischen diesen beiden parteien
ich gucke haben meine kommentare und
merkel vor allem markus söder spaltet
hier unser publikum also mario kessel
schreibt so da wird durch die presse
zerstört mathilde die passqualität
runter meint söder hat das zeug zum
kanzler mit drei daumen hoch und
darunter wiederum hatten und klein meint
so dass ein gefährlicher mann und
unberechenbar also wirklich sehr
kontrovers das ganze war das denn jetzt
abzusehen aus ihrer perspektive als
politikbeobachter oder kommt dieser
streit jetzt doch ein bisschen
überraschend eben weil sie da immer
gesagt hat mein platz ist in bayern eine
sich überraschend denn das war abzusehen
dass er am ende doch auch in den ring
springt und bis sonntag war das auch
clever angelegt weitgehend clever im
moment wirkt es überzogen aber so wie
das die kommentare und die e mail
anfragen bei ihnen ja auch dokumentieren
und in den chats in den foren diskutiert
wird er polarisiert also wieder
polarisiert und das ist auch das neues
die jetzige bundeskanzlerin war unfähig
zur polarisierung und hat auch unwillig
bitte auch unwillig ja unwillig und
heroisch auf ihre art und insofern immer
auf der suche auch nach neuen ideen wie
eine themen die bienen auch durchaus
unterwegs und hat dadurch auch es schwer
gemacht dagegen zu mobilisieren und wer
jetzt stark polarisiert er glaubt auch
sehr stark mobilisieren zu können aber
die kehrseite ist eine gegend
mobilisierung die natürlich auch ein
jetzt bei allen die dann widerstand
karte zu spüren
vielleicht mal ein bisschen weiter
hinten angesetzt weil wir nehmen das
immer so selbstverständlich hin union
ist csu und cdu und die csu darf
mitreden was den kanzler kandidaten oder
die kandidatin angeht aber vielleicht
doch mal wirklich das fragezeichen
dahinter was ist das eigentlich für ein
gemenge lager wenn man einfach mal jetzt
so oben drauf guckt könnte man ja auch
saatgut das ist der bayerische
landesverband von der cdu also sowas wie
ein kleines anhängsel wieso dürfen die
sich immer so aufspielen sag ich jetzt
mal zugespitzt
gute beobachtung weil der bundestagswahl
rund 20 prozent am ergebnis der cd der
union insgesamt trägt die csu mit bei
ist also nicht nicht zu viel aber es ist
immer wieder ein hoher prozentsatz und
die csu ist die drittstärkste
mitgliederstärkste partei in der
bundesrepublik deutschland durchaus groß
und von der geschichte her rektors eben
damit zusammen dass es zwei
unterschiedliche parteien geblieben sind
konrad adenauer wurde erster
bundeskanzler 1949 als cdu bundeskanzler
aber ohne dass es bisher eine bundes
partei damals überhaupt gab jetzt erst
nach der wahl gegründet die union setzt
sich aus unionisten geradezu aus unions
zellen in einzelnen städten in ländern
in teilen damals in der nachkriegszeit
zusammen und wurde erst mal zu 50
ebenfalls föderales gebildet
zusammengeführt und der freistaat war
eben heroisch als freistaat er wollte
nicht mitmachen er blieb alleine und
insofern ist es eine zusammenarbeit
zwischen zwei selbstständigen partei die
eine einzige klammert organisatorisch
und das ist im bundestag und deswegen
kommt es morgen durchaus darauf an da
genauer hinzuschauen immer nach einer
wahl nach einer bundestagswahl wird
diese fraktionsgemeinschaft neu
etabliert sie ist nicht fest gefügt sie
wird immer wieder neu beschworen und sie
wird neu vereinbart mit einer
gemeinsamen geschäftsordnung aber die
partei csu lebt auch im bundestag als
eigene partei
durch diese fraktionsgemeinschaft ist
eine große kuriosität aber die größe der
csu hängt immer
zusammen dass sie auf beiden feldern
eben aktiv ist wenn sie nur ab
bundespolitik docht wird es nicht
ankommen und nur als regionalpartei
würde sie unterschätzt diese zweiter
position macht sie attraktiv nach wie
vor und auch stark ich habe jetzt jede
menge fragen auch zu diesem jahr
verhältnis gerade was du das auch die
beliebtheit angeht von herrn laschet und
herrn söder das besprechen wir gleich
würde ich sagen gucken was noch mal
genauer an denn ich möchte das gab noch
mal bei dieser historie bleiben denn
dieser streit zwischen cdu und csu wer
denn jetzt kanzlerkandidat werden
sondern der kandidat in der ist nicht
das erste mal da den haben wir schon ein
paar mal gehabt und das ganze haben nach
hin zu finden und die hand frederike
fischer für uns mal kurz zusammengefasst
quasi der blick in die geschichte
strauß stoiber und nun söder
die drei csu politiker teilen nicht nur
den anfangsbuchstaben sondern auch den
willen kanzler zu werden
1980 tritt csu mann franz josef strauß
für die union an dieser kanzler kandidat
polarisiert
am ende bleibt helmut schmidt von der
spd kanzler 2002 edmund stoiber zieht
für die union in den bundestagswahlkampf
gegen die rot grüne koalition nachdem
angela merkel ihm beim legendären
wolfratshauser frühstück das feld
überlässt wieder eine niederlage für den
csu kandidaten
die spd gewinnt schröder bleibt kanzler
jetzt fast 20 jahre später wird wieder
ein csu mann seinen hut in den ring
markus söder ist im rennen gegen armin
laschet in der hoffnung der erste
kanzler der csu zu werden
ja also kann man eigentlich sagen
business as usual herr korte oder also
das ist ja nichts neues
streiten sie hat und am ende zumindest
zwei fundamental unterschiede damals bei
beiden vorgängern waren stark gegen
kanzler im amt das kann man schon mal
heute nicht sagen der die kanzlerin
tritt nicht mehr an
insofern ist die besonderheit jetzt eine
andere die um vergleichbar ist damals
war es eben schröder und es war schmidt
als gegen kanzler und die zweite große
unterschiedlichkeit damals in der
aussage
liegt darin dass die cdu sich niemals
auf einen auf einen kandidaten vorab
geeinigt hatte das starke
ministerpräsident starke mitglieder des
präsidiums gab die gleichermaßen für die
csu für strauß damals oder für stoiber
optimierten diese stimmen gibt es heute
nicht darauf setzt ja im moment also
dass er sie mit einer korea taktik
geradezu lostreten kann dass wir sie
hören aber bisher waren sie nicht zu
wenn insofern ist die kreative
auseinandersetzung der beiden parteien
sich im wettbewerb zu testen
durchaus teil auch der geschichte aber
die stärke bei bundestagswahlen hieß
liegt lag immer daran dass man ab sich
beim gemeinsamen kandidaten verständigt
hat und gemeinsam auch mobilisiert hat
dass es extrem wichtig die uneinigkeit
der partei hat in der letzten
auseinandersetzung zwischen frau merkel
und herrn seehofer beide damals
parteivorsitzender nach der letzten
bundestagswahl dramatische umfrage
abstürze gebracht und hat keiner der
beiden parteien gold also wir werden
quasi gerade historische also zeit
zeugen einer historischen wende in der
union können uns quasi t shirts machen
kanzlerfrage 2021 ich war dabei
kommen wir mal zu den ganzen fragen weil
wir haben hier viele fragen die sagen
also da ist doch beliebter und es wird
auch gerade ihr vorgeworfen wir hätten
zu negativ über herrn söder berichtet
und zu positiv überrascht ich glaube
dass die tatsächlich einfach daran das
würde ich jetzt mal ein journalist sagen
dass herr söder einfach mehr
angriffsfläche diese dass man da mehr
kritisieren kann das scheint mir bei
hannah schmitt manchmal ein bisschen
schwierig zu sein aber genauso dieses
öffentliche image das die beiden haben
das ist ja sehr unterschiedlich zeigt
sich auch in den zustimmungswerten wie
erklären sie sich dass herr kostet das
die beiden so unterschiedlich
wahrgenommen werden
ja ich muss mal sehen was ist heute und
was ist bei der bundestagswahl wenn wir
bei der bundestagswahl davon ausgehen
dass wir eine geimpfte republik haben
und wir alle vielleicht schon einmal im
urlaub waren wird die perspektive noch
klarer auf eine zukunft wie wird der
residente staat aussehen die
zukunftsfähigkeit des vorsorge statt
ausgerichtet sei nun nicht
die krisensituationen und die
krisenbewältigung in der aktuellen
situation der momentaufnahmen haben wir
nur bewertungen dieses managen der
korona politik und da sehen wir zwei
führungs und kommunikationsstil die
nicht unterschiedlicher sein könnten die
gleichermaßen der gesellschaft populär
sind
da ist einmal das kooperative wie es mit
armin laschet vor macht fast mit einer
empathischen führungs vorstellung
unterschiede heterogenität auch
einzubinden eigene kabinett die
unterschiede stark zu machen und damit
zu werben das gemeinsame insgesamt im
blick zu haben
aber nicht vorzupreschen das ist post
heroes und das daneben dass ein führungs
und kommunikationsstil von söder der es
hier ruhiger kommt ja ja das ist
entschieden heitz prosa es ist die
sehnsucht die ihr damit befriedet nach
einer verlässlichen autorität einer
sicheren anker der sagt wie es
weitergeht in der krise für beides gibt
es hohe zustimmungswerte für beide steht
der kommunikation die frage ist ob am
bundestags termin welcher dieser
sehnsüchte am ehesten befriedet wäre
wenn wir zwischen diesen beiden
kandidaten zu entscheiden aber wenn sie
gerade sagen das tier danach ist eine an
es gibt hohe zustimmungswerte dann
müssen wir doch sagen gerade sind die
umfragen zumindest eher auf der seite
von herrn söder der jetzt aber gerade in
dieser kanzlerfrage nicht so gut daher
kommt das heißt gerade dieser krise
scheinen sich die befragten eher nach
dieser helden erzählen wie sie das
nennen nach dieser heroischen figur zu
sehen die sagt ich regel das wir euch ja
also es wird ja nicht konkret der
führungs und kommunikationsstil
abgefragt sondern krisen management und
da drückt sich das aus aber das wissen
wir eben dass sich deswegen weil sich
daraufhin in einigen monaten eine andere
stimmung sein kann so dass vielleicht
der bedarf etwas zusammen zu halten
einen modernisierungskurs zu fahren der
nicht als masterplan daherkommt sondern
vielleicht gemeinsam dialogischer
inklusive mit anderen macht
vorstellungen erarbeitet wird auf höhere
zustimmung stößt zumindest im
bildungsbürgerlichen milieu als
diejenigen die immer nur auf einen
entschiedenheit waren eine ansage das
ist insofern der jetzt siege im moment
den wir bemessen und nicht den im
september und söder setzt natürlich auch
die jetzigen werte wenngleich die
empirie der krisenbewältigung in bayern
nicht besser ist als in nrw auch das
macht eher kommunikativ geschickt wir
haben aber den eindruck es gibt dort
weniger tote weniger incidents werte
clevere lösung das ist nicht der fall
das passt jetzt aber auch zu der frage
die hier von mehreren gestellt wird also
einmal von winter- auf youtube stürzt
die union sich nicht selbst in den ruin
wenn sie nach all den negativen
ereignissen klammer auf
korruptionsskandale darf war ja was mit
masken und soko corinna management
debakel auch noch den extreme
unbeliebten kandidaten wählt oder
barbara baraka auf facebook wird reese
aufruf zerstört die cdu hier realität
bereitet sich die cdu/csu mit dieser
offenen machtfrage in der hoch-zeit der
pandemie auf ihre rolle als opposition
für also zerstört die cdu sich gerade
selber ja das könnte man nach heutigen
tag meinen müsste man schlecht stärker
als frage formulieren gegenüber der csu
denn er hatte bis gestern abend oder
wenn man bis heute mittag die große
chance vielleicht darauf zu verzichten
und als sonnenkönig noch einmal
zusätzlich nach bayern zurückzukehren er
das optimum herausgeholt dass man ihm
die kanzlerkandidatur wie auf jeden fall
zu tat und dass er aus größe heraus
darauf verzichtet und triumphiert nach
bayern praktisch zurückkommt das hätte
man anerkannt im moment setzte er aber
auf eine zermürbende geradezu zersetzung
taktik innerhalb der cdu
und das wird der union insgesamt
umfragewerten schaden wie man das clever
macht auch innerhalb der eigenen partei
mit zwei vorsitzenden sieht man bei den
grünen
da sind wir jetzt erwartungsvoll dass
sie sich in aller ruhe die beiden
verständigen
jetzt kommen wir zu den positionen her
gab sonntag fragen so wo steht
eigentlich wer zb von dem menschen mit
dem schönen usernamen mistral auf reis
vermutlich dann lieblingsgericht um die
politischen standpunkte beider besser
einordnen zu können welche koalitions
kommen
nationen wären beide jeweils zu bezahlen
also wo steht quasi bär oder
unterscheiden die sich so gar nicht so
ein guter hinweis weil die deutschen
sind zunehmend immer mehr auch
strategische koalitions wähler
man möchte fans des erfolgs eine
regierungskoalition am ende sein und
schon sich vorstellen dass man teil
einer erfolgsgeschichte ist eine
regierung mit konstruiert zu haben
sofern wählt man auch mit den beiden
stimmen unterschiedliche parteien häufig
und bildet sich ein damit es auch
entscheidend zu beeinflussen aber man
spricht auch im freundeskreis darüber so
dass sich daraus ein gesamtbild ergibt
insofern ist schon die frage wer zu wem
besser passt im moment gehen wir davon
aus dass die grünen ein guter partner
wären und man kann sich in der tat das
auch sehr gut vorstellen weil asche noch
mehr als bass oder laschet favorisiert
im moment die fdp als partner weil er
damit sehr gute erfahrungen in
düsseldorf hat für ihn könnte er auch
ein jamaika format sich vermutlich gut
vorstellen aber es ist eben nicht gesagt
dass die union wieder die stärkste
fraktion im bundestag wird es kann auch
sein dass wir die grünen diesmal
erstmals die stärkste fraktion im
bundestag stellen und dann sieht die
konstellation natürlich für die union
komplett anders als habe die
unterschiede wer mit wem
zusammenarbeitet sehe ich nicht so
markant dass daran eine koalition
scheitern will söder oder dass sie
finden partner in der politischen mitte
und können mit denen zusammenarbeit
dann geht es hier eine frage von samy
was genau macht das jetzt politisch für
ein unterschied zwischen söder und
laschet also haben die tatsächlich
irgendwo ein punkt wo man sagen kann ok
wer für das eine ist der sollte söder
favorisieren dafür dass andere ist
laschet oder sind sie auch da eigentlich
nur von ihrem politikstil zu
unterscheiden
ja ich sehe hier nur unterschied im stil
wie man miteinander macht ausübt und wie
man auch ein macht verständnis hat das
ist fundamental anders in der
programmatik sehe ich keine großen
unterschiedlichen linien das lasche
stärker industriepolitisch geprägt ist
durch
nrw ist glaube ich naheliegend und das
stärker als laschet das ökologische ins
zentrum gerückt hat nach der letzten
landtagswahl mit den sehr schlechten
ergebnissen für die csu ist auch
erkennbar aber das sind marginalen
unterschied es geht ja darum einen
reformkurs für die union zu projizieren
in den nächsten wochen mit einem
alleinstellungsmerkmal wie man einen
residenten staat schafft unter den
bedingungen die wir jetzt kennengelernt
haben mit aufklärerische wirkung haben
wir ja durch das virus erkannt dass
alles schlecht läuft und gibt es ein
plan der nicht nur als
reparaturwerkstatt daherkommt sondern
als eine große erzählung wer ist er in
der lage eine große erzählung dazu zu
machen die auch stimmig wirkt darin
werden vielleicht unterschiede erkennbar
aber so weit ist die union überhaupt
noch nicht hier geht's jetzt ein paar
kommentatorinnen die ihm vorwerfen sie
werden partei für herrn laschet weil sie
immer wieder sagen er wird
wahrscheinlich der kasseler kandidat der
union vielleicht können sie das mal
erklären wie sie zu diesem urteil kommen
ist das ihre persönliche präferenz nein
damit das wäre ich ja als
politikwissenschaftler der das zu
analysieren hatte habe ich keine
persönlichen präferenz sein
ich sehe das von der größenverhältnis
erstmal und von der historischen
konstellation die historische
konstellation habe ich vorhin ein wenig
erläutert ich sehe keinen vergleich so
ich sehe eine gestärkte cdu die sich
hinter ihren kandidaten gestellt hat und
insofern unterscheidet dass das von den
historischen vorgängen da waren die
linien nicht geschlossen da war es
trockener und annahmen andere eher
zurückgezogen oder andere ins feld
geführt das ist insofern diesmal anders
und bei dieser konstellation wird die
cdu und den unions gedanken
aufrechtzuhalten auf einvernehmen setzen
einvernehmen heißt also gemütlich sich
zu verständigen am besten bilateral
nicht mit mehrheiten zu entscheiden
sonst ist die union letztlich zerplatzt
geradezu das einvernehmen heißt ein
dialog prozess zu beginn zwischen den
beiden personen und da sich ein
die chancen am ende für laschet daraus
doch als sieger hervorzugehen er gesetzt
als für söder
zumal der rückzug für laschet eine
fundamentale schlappe nicht nur für ihn
wäre sondern eben für die union
insgesamt ich weiß nicht wie die union
sich davon erholen könnte dass ihr
kandidat nicht antritt zurückziehen muss
der gerade frisch als bundesvorsitzender
her gewählt ist sind dieses höchste
integration sagte der rückzug für söder
würde gerade zu blöd so fern sind die
fallhöhen auch dabei sehr
unterschiedlich also es gibt hier ich
bekomme meine kommentare wirklich sehr
sehr unterschiedliche wortmeldungen zu
den beiden die einheiten
laschet für einen nerv nerven also und
jemand der sein fähnchen nach dem wind
dreht andere finden söder gingen nicht
mit seinem politikstil weil viel zu
aggressiv so will ich das jetzt mal
zusammenfassen also da gibt es kritik an
beiden irgendwie aber wenn sie jetzt
gerade sagen im grunde die cdu ist die
größere partei ist die größere fraktion
im bundestag hat deswegen ihren cdu-chef
und muss ihn eigentlich durch drücken um
nicht komplett blöd dazustehen
das musste auch markus söder wissen
warum macht er dann trotzdem weiter
diesem dieses theater das sieht ja fast
nach einem schaukampf aus dass es sind
sofern auch um 24 stunden aus meinen
dass sich über reids es gibt solche kipp
punkte an dem man nicht mehr erreicht
sondern indem man macht abstieg
eigentlich erkennbar ist und ihr kollege
aus münchen hat ja heute schon
beobachtet die wachsende csu nervosität
offenbar und scheint man auch zu einem
bewusstsein zu kommen dass man
vielleicht über drehen könnte hat am
morgen noch die chance nach den
anhörungen im bundestag vielleicht auch
darauf zu verzichten ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass er das weiter so
aufreizend will weil er kann am ende
dadurch dann doch verlieren bis zu einem
gewissen punkt ist das dann nicht mehr
steigerbar und dann ist der machtverfall
für ihn damit auch verbunden und damit
auch etwas was er überreizt hat was er
nicht erreicht hat kommt zu einem
schlechten ende
jetzt habe ich hier eine frage noch zum
abschluss die aus verschiedenen
positionen immer wieder gestellt wird
der max der hat
ganz große frage können wir kurz mal
stellen hier auf dem rechner schalten
die immer wieder gepostet hat deswegen
also eigentlich nehmen wir nicht die
drängen da dran lieber max
ja weil du hast die frage jetzt wirklich
15 mal gepostet aber ich finde sie
berechtigt deswegen machen wir eine
ausnahme
also was bedeutet das verhalten von
söder und laschet jetzt für die grünen
ist da gab es auch glaube ich noch mal
eine ähnliche frage die sich jetzt nicht
mehr also tatsächlich was heißt das
jetzt im grunde für die für die grünen
die in umfragen sehr sehr gut dastehen
für das jetzt im endeffekt zwangsläufig
zu einer grünen kanzlerin oder einem
grünen kanzler weil die union sich
gerade selber ins knie schießt nein das
kann man so nicht sehen aber die grünen
brauchen wenn sie regieren wollen
natürlich auch partner und so wie sie im
moment aufgestellt sind wäre die union
sicherlich einen partner mit dem sie gut
über koalitionsziele verhandeln könnten
das kann mit der spd auch so sein sie
sind ja multi koalitionsfähig in vielen
bundesländern mitregieren mit
unterschiedlichen partei also ich sehe
nicht dass sie im moment für den einer
für andere größere favoriten rolle
spielen würden aber insgesamt glaube ich
geht es darum dass die politische mitte
weil der bundestagswahl größer und
breiter wird wie sie bei den letzten
landtagswahlen in mainz und stuttgart
auch geworden ist die bunte sie sortiert
sich neu sofern haben die grünen ein
interesse an einem stabilen partner der
auch selbstbewusst agiert mit starken
selbstbewussten koalitionspartner kann
man auch gute koalitionsverhandlungen
führen hat aber eben bestimmt mit einer
union die geschwächt ist die nicht an
sich selbst glaubt ist es schwer eine
gute partnerschaft zu knüpfen insofern
glaube ich sind sie durchaus daran
interessiert dass die union tritt fasst
jetzt gibt sie eine beschwerde noch zu
unserem gespräch das wir nicht darüber
reden was diese leute planen welche
inhalte sie haben von christ ja was ihre
idee ist es würde immer nur darum gehen
wer von denen immer in den medien besser
performt aber sie haben ja gerade schon
festgestellt der professor korte dass
sie im endeffekt identisch sind in dem
wofür sie stehen für die für die
inhaltliche politik von daher ist es ja
schon interessant einfach super
wie die sich jeweils verhalten und wie
das bei den wählern ankommt oder aber
aber trotzdem würde man ja idealtypisch
davon ausgehen dass ein vorsitz eine
kandidatur für eine kanzlerschaft auch
inhaltlich begründet wird und man
unterschiedliche richtungen fährt über
wochen verfolgen konnte mit denen beide
sich profiliert japan siehe nicht und
wenn sie jetzt darauf sagt setzt er hat
viel zeit dann hätte natürlich die zeit
ist nämlich praktisch nicht mehr da auch
vor vier wochen schon kandidieren können
oder seinen namen dann offiziell machen
können für die kandidatur aber so wie
sie das im chat ja auch haben glaube ich
sehen dass viele bürgerinnen und bürger
worin unterscheiden sie sich innerlich
in der perspektive der programmatik was
sie uns nach der bundestagswahl als
besondere alleinstellungsmerkmale
problem lösen für die cdu/csu vorstellen
wollte gibt es da markante unterschiede
im modernisierungs reformkonzept für für
die bundesrepublik deutscher das würde
uns das hirn und dann könnte man auch
sagen da würden unterschiede sichtbar
kann ich im moment nicht erkennen das
ist eine sehr verkürzte
auseinandersetzung zwischen beiden
personen die aber nicht mit inhalten
zusammen insofern eine eine
richtungsdiskussion die wir nicht in
wirklichkeit kennen ja dann könnte man
doch darüber reden wenn sie uns sagen
würden wofür sie stehen aber im
endeffekt frage stehen sie können wir
das fest zu satz zusammenfassen am
schluss vor allem für sich selber wir
sind gespannt wie das ausgeht der
profitrate ja naja also die union hat
natürlich bestimmte werte aus denen sie
ihre programmatik entwickelt also setzen
so hat das jahr haben sie beide auch
angedeutet schon natürlich mehr auf
eigenverantwortung mehr aber das ist das
was die union so ausmacht als partei
haben
das ist ja nicht dass das jetzt der eine
oder andere betont dass er also zum
beispiel die friedrich merz sagt ich
setze auf ganz viel eigenverantwortung
und auch eine starke wirtschaft und
umweltschutz ist auch wichtig aber nicht
ganz so wichtig da scheinen sie ja doch
relativ identisch zu sein aber über das
parteiprogramm der cdu/csu werdender in
den nächsten wochen und monaten auch
noch viel reden wahrscheinlich auch mit
ihnen herr professor korte erfahre ich
erst mal vielen dank für ihre
einschätzungen und wir sind gespannt wie
dieses duell weiter geht hier ja erst
mal blauen punkt
gut dann danke ich ihnen und euch auch
für die fragen und kommentare und bin
gespannt wie das ganze jetzt tatsächlich
sich in den nächsten stunden oder tagen
weiterentwickelt wir sind auf jeden fall
dabei für euch und berichten entweder
hier oder zum beispiel in unserer zdf
heute ab die natürlich schon längst
geladen hat wird nicht seine renn
schnell hin oder auf www zdf heute.de da
könnte auch mal vorbeischauen also wir
sind auf jeden fall für euch da aber für
heute macht man punkt und ich sage
vielen akris dabei sein
bis zum nächsten mal und tschüss